[APPLAUSE]
SARAH MURRAY: Welcome everybody.
I'm really thrilled to be here
to talk about Christine's book.
I just thought
I'd show you this.
Because this is how--
CHRISTINE BADER: She's
done her homework.
SARAH MURRAY: --interested
I was in this book.
I'm not going to be reading
every single excerpt from it,
you'll be pleased to hear.
But I kept running
out of colors.
So every page I was like,
ah, this is so interesting.
So, yeah.
I mean for me, having covered
these issues for so many years,
this was an absolutely
fascinating book for me to read
because I think as a journalist
you, to a large extent,
feel on the outside
of all these issues.
And so for me it
was just wonderful,
and you do it so well Christine,
to have this story told
from the inside of
the big corporations
that I'm not normally ever
allowed to go in and examine
at that sort of level of depth.
And the other thing that
you did really well,
as a corporate
idealist you bring
in all these other
corporate idealists
sort of later in
the book as well.
And Christine's kind of
created with the book
a kind of amazing
community of people.
And for me it was really
wonderful because actually,
a lot of these people I've
interviewed over the years.
And it was wonderful to kind
of reconnect with these people
through your books.
So thank you for that.
CHRISTINE BADER: Oh good, Sarah.
You know, it was fun for me
too to do all these interviews,
because a lot of
them were people
who I'd known for a long time.
Professionally we all go
to the same conferences.
But I'd never actually
gotten to talk to them
about how they feel about
their work and their ups
and downs and their struggles,
and when their company's just
deeply disappointed them
and what that was like.
So it was good fun for me too.
SARAH MURRAY: Well
on that point there's
a really good line right at the
beginning that I'll just read,
because it speaks very
much to that point.
This is in the
introduction and Christine
writes, "We believe
that business
can be a force for good
even as we struggle
with our own contradictions."
I think that's a theme that
runs through the whole book
and is very
powerfully expressed.
But I thought I'd start by,
let's go back to the beginning.
Because you describe
your relationship
with BP and the corporate world
as something of a love affair.
And of course, it
was a love affair
that was going to
sort of fall apart
after the Deepwater
Horizon took place.
So just tell us how that
love affair started.
What was the spark that made
you think that, gosh, business
might actually be a force
for good in the world?
CHRISTINE BADER: Right.
OK, that's good, Sarah.
That's a good place to start.
So I had done nonprofit
and government work
and then decided to go
to business school, first
of all like every good
liberal arts graduate.
But then also I realized
that in these jobs
I seem to be reacting to things
that the private sector had
done.
So when I was doing
community service, when
I was working in the New
York City mayor's office,
we were reacting
to the conditions
that business had created.
So I was serving
in communities that
had been devastated when
companies had moved out
or they had actively
done things bad,
like they had lobbied to replace
a public garden with a parking
lot.
Or they had moved into
an area and failed
to hire anybody from that city.
And then in the mayor's
office, on the flip side,
companies were wooed for
the jobs and for the revenue
that they bring in.
And so there was always this
sort of balance of OK, well,
we clearly need to
regulate business
but we want to encourage them.
So that's why I chose
to go to business school
because I thought, OK.
Business actually seems to be
pretty important in the world.
I should learn something
about the private sector.
So I went.
But of course I had no
idea what I wanted to do.
Did any of you go
to business school?
Yeah.
And so you get there
and people immediately
start asking you to throw
your resumes in for investment
banking or consulting
interviews.
And you get there and you're
like, I don't know what this is
and I haven't
learned anything new.
So I started to follow
the herd and do that.
But then John Browne, who at
the time was the CEO of BP,
came to speak at Yale.
And he had recently become the
first head of a major energy
company to acknowledge the
realities of climate change
and urge action.
And he was a really inspiring
and thoughtful leader.
And I thought, oh.
This is what business can do.
That is intriguing to me.
So that's why I joined,
because of this leader who
seemed to be a different
kind of oil man,
trying to create a different
kind of energy company.
And it was really intriguing.
So I joined and I went
straight out to Indonesia.
And the thing that turned
out to be my job in Indonesia
and China was investing in the
communities living near big BP
projects.
Because everybody
who I worked with
realized that what was
good for those communities
was good for our business.
There were lots of
other terrible examples
around the world of where
community relations have gone
sour and communities
have blockaded access
roads to mines, they've
sabotaged equipment.
So people seem to
understand that
what was good for
them was good for us.
And that was my job.
So I was living this cliche
of doing well and doing good.
I mean, what's not to love?
SARAH MURRAY: And was this
something that came up
when you were at
business school?
I mean, were these
kinds of issues--
I mean, I know now business
schools have been piling
on the courses about
sort of sustainability
and corporate responsibility.
But back then was that
something that was covered?
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah,
not specifically.
I mean, I chose to go to
Yale for business school
because its mission
has always been
to educate leaders for
business and society.
So there's always been this
sort of ethos there of, yes.
We go there in order to do some
sort of service to the world.
And people who go
there choose to do it
through business or
working with business.
But no.
At the time there weren't sort
of corporate responsibility
jobs or sustainability jobs.
SARAH MURRAY: Right.
Right.
But then now, so you've
sort of met-- well,
not met John Browne,
but seen him speak
and kind of bought
into this idea
that BP could be
a force for good.
And then you're in
a helicopter flying
over the jungles of Indonesia.
Now, what is going through
your head at that point?
CHRISTINE BADER: Right.
So I went out to Indonesia.
I spent my summer internship
between my two years
of business school in
London headquarters,
and then my first assignment
with BP was out in Indonesia.
But again, this
wasn't a CSR job.
I was supposed to be a
commercial analyst using
my new spreadsheet skills.
And BP had just taken over
ARCO, the American oil company.
And so I was there.
A lot of the ARCO
stuff was in Indonesia.
So I was analyzing
those projects.
There were lots of different
oil fields, gas fields.
There was some coal,
some solar, chemicals.
What should BP keep?
What should it spin off?
What should it do
with all this stuff?
So I was just crunching
numbers and doing spreadsheets
because that's what
you do when you've
graduated from business school.
I didn't know that
this was a job.
But one of those
projects was proving
particularly
interesting, and not
from a technical point of view.
From a technical point of view
it was very straightforward.
So there was a big gas field and
BP was going to build a plant,
a liquefied natural gas LNG
plant to process the gas.
And that's pretty
straightforward.
BP's done that all
over the world.
But never in a place
like this where
we were going to have to work
with the Indonesian military,
which is not known for their
good community relations.
And a village was
going to have to be
moved to make way for the plant.
It was 127 families.
SARAH MURRAY: Not to
mention the forest
that you were flying over.
CHRISTINE BADER: Exactly.
So my first trip
out there, yeah.
And I was living in Jakarta
in Indonesia's capital.
And so to get out
to West Papua I
had to take an overnight
commercial flight and then
a little seaplane-- it was
like a twelve seater plane--
another hour and a half,
and then a helicopter
the rest of the way in.
So on that last
leg of the journey
there's this really
dense rainforest
through flocks of birds
bursting through the trees.
Not a lot of people.
And as we started
to get closer I
could see the rig on
the horizon in the bay.
And as we're coming
in, I could just
see our landing pad and then
the dormitories for the workers
there.
And we're on the equator.
It was pretty hot.
I had never been in
a helicopter before.
This was pretty exciting.
But I was starting to get
really sweaty and uncomfortable.
And I realized that
I was envisioning
the sketches of what the
plant was going to look like.
And it was this gleaming, modern
industrial complex and imposing
it on this not totally pristine,
but relatively pristine
rainforest.
And I started to get really ill.
I just thought for
the first time, oh.
This is what we do.
SARAH MURRAY: Not
something they prepare you
for at business school.
CHRISTINE BADER: No, I mean,
I understand conceptually.
Like, yeah.
We keep the lights on and we
help keep the cars moving.
But that's when
it really hit me.
And so we landed.
And you can't really
talk in a helicopter
because it's pretty loud.
But I was there with one
of the vice presidents
for environmental policy,
and she immediately
saw the distress on my face.
And she said, that's
why we're here.
We're going to get this right.
SARAH MURRAY: Now what does
getting it right it mean?
Because I mean, I
think it would be
interesting to talk a little bit
about perceptions of business
and how business
operates and what
the realities are on the ground.
Because I certainly get a
sense often in the people
that I talk to that aren't
in the business world,
that they think,
well, business is
just this evil empire that comes
in and lands, and that's it.
And the reality on the
ground and the things
that you were then
going to deal with
is sort of complex and messy.
And how much of that is the
company's responsibility,
and how much are you dealing
with the existing environment
and having to sort of
negotiate all these
very complex trade offs?
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah,
that's exactly the question,
and this company knows
that as well as anyone.
And we can get into
that certainly as well.
So I guess the first fundamental
macro concept is the point
that energy does
keep the lights on
and it helps enable
the lifestyles that we
want to lead.
And so I suppose
there are plenty
of people who want to try to
stop globalization and stop
development altogether.
And that's fine.
There should be some
people who want to do that.
I mean, I can get a little bit
snarky with them and ask well,
who keeps your lights on and
how did you get here today,
and what made that possible?
SARAH MURRAY: We live part
of the corporate world
as consumers and
individuals, don't we?
CHRISTINE BADER: Exactly.
I mean, one thing that
I do once in awhile
is just a little game, which I
invite you all to play with me.
But just stop and take
an inventory, right?
I just stop and say, OK.
Head to toe, what am I wearing
right now and what's in my bag?
And how many companies
or brands have I
interacted with since
I woke up this morning?
So I've got a coffee maker
and I've got my alarm clock,
and I woke up in my sheets that
were made here and bought here.
And I just go through, OK.
Well, what do I know
about these companies?
And where does
that put me on the
responsible to
overconsumption spectrum?
SARAH MURRAY: Right.
And I think what's interesting,
and this is particularly true,
I guess, of sort of
apparel industries
and food which have very
complex supply chains.
But even with energy
you turn the lights on
and you don't think about
that Indonesian villager that
had to move to another
village or to a new village.
What were the real on
the ground challenges
that you didn't expect and that
certainly business school might
not have prepared you for?
[LAUGHTER]
SARAH MURRAY: Some of
the sort of nitty gritty.
I mean, I think
there was something
you mentioned about the
fact that this was really
interesting to me,
that you made it
so that the workers did
not get paid on site.
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah.
That's right.
SARAH MURRAY: That
for me reflected
a lot of the
complexities that you're
dealing with on the ground.
So perhaps just explain that.
CHRISTINE BADER: Sure,
I can explain that.
So we were building this big
plant in a really remote area.
There was one village there
but no other cities nearby.
So we stipulated in the contract
with the construction company
that they would not hire
or pay people on the site.
They would only do that in
one of the three existing
towns that were a
little ways away.
The reason is that if you
let it be known that you're
going to be hiring
people right at the site,
people move right
up to the fence.
And then they usually, if
they can't get a job because
there aren't that
many jobs, than they
tap into the electricity.
They stay there
because they've moved.
And that's how
shantytowns pop up.
And then idol hands, right?
And that's how bad things
arise, because then also,
if you pay people
on site, imagine
if somebody's done
a three week shift
and then they stand there.
They walk out of a
plant and you hand them
three weeks worth
of cash, and they're
not home with
their families yet.
You might imagine what pops up.
So then brothels pop up.
Sort of ad hoc gambling
parlors pop up.
And then what happens,
then the police
feel like they need to
move in for protection,
but they're actually
taking their cut.
And then the military
step up their presence
because they're
like, wait a second.
The police are getting in
on all the action, right?
So you can see how these
things start to compound.
So that's why we didn't
want to hire [INAUDIBLE].
SARAH MURRAY: It's really
so complex, isn't it?
For so many industries.
One of the things
I thought would
be interesting to ask you about
was where you see-- you talk
a lot in the book about
CSR and later we'll
talk a little bit about
sort of careers in CSR
and how you move into that.
Personally I hate the term CSR.
I don't know about you.
Because I think it sort
of silos these things
into some kind of acronym
that half the world
doesn't know what
that means anyway.
So where do you see the balance?
A lot of companies will talk
about their sustainability
program or their business
responsibility program.
And then you find
that they're talking
about changing the light bulbs
in the office or recycling
things.
What you've just described
on the ground in Indonesia,
to me that's corporate
responsibility.
How do you see that sort
of view in business,
that attitude having shifted?
Or has it shifted?
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah,
I agree with you.
I mean, the term corporate
social responsibility
sort of drives me crazy
because it can mean everything
and it can mean nothing.
So I definitely
see the same thing.
And I think that the benefit is
that so many more companies are
comfortable talking about
that, whatever it is.
So it actually gets them
to the table, right?
And so I have a
nice quote in there
from Aron Cramer who runs
BSR, Business for Social
Responsibility.
And he says the trick is
to get them to the table
and then move the table.
Right?
So the point is to get
more and more companies
in talking about corporate
social responsibility,
talking about sustainability.
So you get them into
the conversation
and then try to explain it.
OK.
Actually this is what we're
really talking about here.
We're not actually
talking about sending out
employees in matching
t-shirts to go
paint a wall for
five hours a week.
Like, that's great
as is recycling
and as are these other
programs, but that's
actually not what we're
talking about here, right?
We're talking about what are
the impacts that your core
business has on society?
And I think here
that's become clear
as people have realized
the challenges to privacy
and free expression that your
core business has on the world
and that you as a company have
a responsibility to address.
And the other stuff that
you do is really interesting
and it's really great and
it's really important,
but I would be fine if all the
other stuff sort of fell away
and companies put all of that
time and energy and resource
into their core business.
SARAH MURRAY: Right.
Now the challenge
there though is
that there are
sort of perceptions
of this costing money.
And what is the payback for
resettling an Indonesian
villager?
Just talk a little
bit about working
within a big corporation
on these issues that
are material to the
business or at least,
that you've explained
very well in the book,
are so material to the business.
You know, you may be
surrounded by the skeptics who
go, well, you know,
why are we going
to pay all this money
for something that's
on the other side of the world?
And what are the challenges
of being a corporate idealist
even within a company
like BP which at the time
was really as you say,
trying to do the right thing?
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah, at the
time it was on the projects
that I worked on.
But still, everybody, you
need to justify your cost
and how much you're spending.
So I suppose in Indonesia I
had the mixed blessing of there
being some really horrible
examples nearby of how
much this can actually cost
a company when it goes really
badly.
So on the other end
of Indonesia in Aceh
there was a similar facility,
a liquefied natural gas plant,
that had to shut down for four
months because of basically
a civil war going on around
it that some people accused
that company of exacerbating.
And I did some
research for the book--
I couldn't find
an exact figure--
but I found a bunch
of estimates that
said that that shutdown,
that four month shutdown,
cost Exxon Mobil anywhere from
$100 to $350 million, right?
I mean, even for Exxon, like,
that's kind of a lot of money.
In the same province as the
project that I worked on
is the Freeport McMoRan
Grasberg copper and gold mine.
That's one of the largest
mines in the world.
And they spent something
like $42 million
on security in one year.
And that keeps going up
because when they came in,
they struck a deal with
the national government.
They didn't pay much attention
to local community issues.
And now they've realized
that didn't work.
But it's really hard to
turn these things around
once they've gone wrong.
So I think in oil, gas, and
mining, it's pretty clear now
that you can't operate
these projects well
if you don't invest in
these issues up front.
And other industries are
starting to see that too.
I mean in apparel,
companies have
realized that if you
treat your workers better
they're going to
be more productive,
there'll be less turnover.
So we're seeing that.
And then in the tax sector
too, I think the challenges
to privacy and free
expression demonstrate
that you need the
trust of users.
Right?
That's what your whole
business is built on.
SARAH MURRAY: It's the
license to operate.
CHRISTINE BADER: It's
the license to operate.
That's exactly what it is.
SARAH MURRAY: Yeah.
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah.
And so, you're right.
That's still sometimes,
it's hard to demonstrate
a very specific
return on investment.
So I think it's fine to have
a rigorous debate about that.
Well, do we need to spend this
much or can we spend this much?
I'm not crazy about going
too far down that road.
Because for example
if I say, OK.
Well, I want to
spend $11 million
next year to make sure that
our security arrangements are
in line with international
human rights principles
so that we won't be
complicit in genocide, say.
I don't really want to have this
conversation of saying, well,
I don't know if we
have $11 million.
If we spend, like,
$4 or $5 million,
is there going to
be a 60% chance
that we're complicit
in genocide?
And it's like, OK.
You know what?
This is not-- like, seriously?
I mean, you do have to
have a little bit of that.
But I think it's OK to call
it out when it's ridiculous.
SARAH MURRAY: Right.
Sure.
Yes, yes.
But I guess, and again.
Something you
mentioned in the book
which I thought
was very intriguing
is the whole idea
that in this work
that you're doing,
even if you're not
having to sort of
measure dollar for dollar
and what the return is,
you're essentially doing work
to make something not happen.
CHRISTINE BADER: Yes.
And nobody gets
rewarded for that.
SARAH MURRAY: Yeah.
Yeah.
CHRISTINE BADER: Right?
So one of the people
who I interviewed
manages supply chains
for a really big company.
And she said that one of
their internal awards,
which are really prestigious
in a big company,
went to one of her colleagues
who managed a big safety
disaster.
And she was like, I prevented,
like, 20 of those, right?
But again, nobody gets
rewarded for something
that doesn't happen.
And one of the people
who I interviewed,
Isabella [? O'Covey ?], who runs
the Business and Human Rights
program at Yahoo.
And she was brought in
after Yahoo was compelled
to turn over user information
about the Chinese government
for Shi Tao, a journalist
who was in jail.
And she was brought
in after that.
But now it's been a while.
There's been a lot of
turnover at the company.
And she said that part of the
challenges of doing this work
well is that if
nothing goes wrong,
then you get people sort of
looking around and going,
well, wait.
What are you doing here?
SARAH MURRAY: Yes.
Yes.
CHRISTINE BADER:
Why are you here
with all this budget, right?
And she's like, I'm the one
preventing the bad things
from happening.
But you don't always know that.
SARAH MURRAY: No, that's right.
And those stories
don't come out.
I mean, one of the things
that I think also-- this
is sort of a topic quite
close to my heart--
is the extent to which
companies are or should
be more open and
honest about both
their failings and
their successes.
I mean, people are always
pitching me stories saying,
oh come on.
We've just cut our carbon
footprint by x million tons.
And they don't want to tell
me that the problem they
had doing it I think
because, you know,
there is very much this
sort of corporate message
that has to controlled.
But do you think that
given what's going on--
and I think this
works both ways.
Because a., I think
results in people
not seeing the real
story and so they just
see when the bad thing
happens, they think,
oh well, there's that rotten
corporate sector again.
But by contrast, I was speaking
to somebody the other day
and I was talking about
what I write about.
And she said, oh, well I
try and do the right thing
with business.
And she said, I never
buy anything from Nike.
And I said well actually,
the company's changed.
It actually is now
seen as a gold standard
in managing labor rights
and things like that.
So just how do you see
the evolution of companies
when it comes to sort of
telling their own story
about this stuff?
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah.
You've totally hit
the nail on the head
because one of the challenges
of many of the people
that I interviewed is
I assumed that it would
be with their legal
departments, because I had
some challenges in
BP of commissioning
these human rights
impact assessments
that I then assumed
that we would publish.
And our legal department
was like, oh no.
Can't talk about that.
But actually a
lot of people said
that the challenges were
in their communications
departments because they only
want to tell good stories.
And that's a real
challenge, because being
open about your challenges
is what first of all
creates a more informed
public conversation, right?
I mean, I think that Google
and a lot of your other
peer companies issuing
transparency reports, right?
Like, issuing the
challenges and the requests
that you're getting from
governments for censorship
and for user data is
really important, right?
It helps convey to
people like, OK.
Oh, here's the scale
of the problem.
And maybe we should be turning
our attention to governments
as well.
So I think it's
really important.
And I think, again,
some companies
are starting to
come around to that.
But it's still slow.
SARAH MURRAY: It's a challenge.
And of course, the
danger is as well
that you stick your
head above the parapet
and then you get attacked.
So I remember
writing a piece years
ago about Gap's corporate
responsibility report, which
was a sort of
warts and all thing
where they listed
all their suppliers
and they highlighted where they
had incidents of child labor
in their supply chain.
And while most NGOs and a lot
of the press and the piece
I wrote for the FT was a sort of
fairly balanced piece about why
they were producing
this report, one,
I remember coming home and
watching a local news channel,
and it just said huge abuses
uncovered at Gap factories.
And so the danger, I
guess, is that they
misinterpret that story.
CHRISTINE BADER:
Well, that's right.
But then you know what
happened years later
when that story came
out about The Gap
finding illegal
subcontracting and there
were some kids that were
making Gap Kids clothes.
But that story, I
mean, people stood up.
People like Mary Robinson,
the former president
of Ireland, a former a U.N. High
Commissioner for Human Rights
and other NGOs standing up,
defending The Gap and saying,
hey.
The Gap has been
working on these issues
longer and harder than
any other company.
And frankly, if any
company says that they've
eradicated the problem of sub
subcontracting, they're lying.
So the story kind of went away.
So again, I think that's part
of taking the long term view.
SARAH MURRAY: Right.
Right.
Honesty and openness
builds your credibility,
even if a few
stragglers don't get it.
CHRISTINE BADER: Exactly.
SARAH MURRAY: Yeah.
Yeah.
And another thing that comes
very strongly through the book
is the impact you're making
as a corporate idealist
in these companies.
I mean, I don't know how you
felt when you left your own BA
and headed out hoping to change
the corporate world entirely.
But often there are
battles one has to pick
and there are
compromises to be made.
What do you see as sort of
the balance for you and others
in this world of
trying to achieve
incremental change versus
complete transformation and
are they both
laudable objectives?
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah, I
think they're both important.
And frankly that's the
whole arc of the book
and what compelled me to
write it in the first place
is that I did come charging out
of business school thinking,
I'm going to change the world.
This is going to be awesome.
And then my first few years
with BP I really felt like that.
I was doing amazingly innovative
and progressive and helpful
work around these projects
with the full backing
of senior management.
And I thought, this was amazing.
And then working with colleagues
around the world in BP
who felt the same way, who
were doing the same work.
And then it was after the
Deepwater Horizon disaster.
I had left BP at that point.
But that to me was the
real sort of crisis
of confidence of
that BP that emerged
in the aftermath
of that disaster,
of this sort of reckless,
callous, risk taking company.
It didn't at all
resemble the BP that I
thought I'd gotten to know
so well over the nine years
that I'd been there.
So my first reaction
was, well, hang on.
That's not my BP.
And then my second
reaction was, or was it?
So I started talking
to friends who've
been doing similar work
deep inside big companies
for a long time, like friends
who work in apparel companies
after the Rana Plaza factory
collapse in Bangladesh who
similarly thought, I've been
doing really good supply chain
work for 20 years and we
just killed 1100 people.
So what does it really
mean to do this work?
So it started off as
this personal journey
of trying to understand, trying
to reconcile those two BPs,
and trying to understand the
work that I had done there.
And realizing that
a lot of people
doing this work in big companies
have these similar challenges.
And so what I came to, not
to give away the punchline,
but what I came to was, yes.
If you're going to go work
in a big massive company,
this work is really incremental.
And it's not going
to change overnight.
But that doesn't undo
good work, right?
Again, as long as it's
not, like, a carbon
offset for-- right?
As long as it's
not like, oh, I'm
doing really good
philanthropy for the company
but it's harming people
with its core business.
I really believe that the work
that I was doing in Indonesia
and China was exactly
the kind of work
that we want extractive
companies doing, that we want
them doing around
these big projects that
supply the world's energy.
So there are moments for
transformative change, right?
When you can really
move your company.
There are these moments, right?
And you can really
move your industry.
Like, for example, Google's
part of the Global Network
Initiative which is this really
important initiative that it
was part of creating
with Microsoft,
with Yahoo, with some
socially responsible investors
and some human rights
groups and some academics
to come up with
a code of conduct
to better protect free
expression and privacy.
And that's really important.
And I think that's
transformative.
I mean, it's taken a
while to implement.
But still, that kind of
thing is transformative.
But the day to day
work is much slower.
SARAH MURRAY: Right.
Right.
Now I mean, there are all these
initiatives that you mention.
And in all kinds
of industries there
are collaborations to address
labor abuses in factories
from sort of human rights to
environment collaborations.
Is this enough?
Where do we need to actually
just turn to government to step
in and start-- you see,
despite years of working on,
despite examples like Nike,
despite companies that
have really worked on supply
chain issues in the apparel
industry, we still
have Rana Plaza.
At what point do we have to say,
business can't do this alone
or can't be relied on.
Do we need government to
just set stronger rules?
CHRISTINE BADER:
We absolutely do.
And so, none of the things
that I've talked about
relieve government of
their responsibility.
I mean, if governments
were fulfilling
their responsibilities,
we wouldn't
be having this conversation.
I mean, we would.
Right?
There's no substitute for
strong, smart, good, properly
enforced regulation.
But the problem I think is
that when something bad happens
with a company, the
conversation seems to be,
oh, there go those
evil companies again.
We need stronger regulation.
And it's like, well, we've
got a lot of regulation.
Like, how's that working
out for us, right?
And so to me it's sort of like,
if you're watching a basketball
game and the basketball
players start throwing punches.
And everybody's like,
where are the refs?
Where are the refs?
Well, hang on.
Why are you letting the
players off the hook?
Right?
We can't just look at the refs.
We need the refs.
The refs have to be there.
So there is no substitute
for strong, good regulation.
But regulation takes a
long time to pass, right?
And the companies know
better than anyone
else what's going on inside.
So that's the focus here.
But I do talk a bit about
the role of government,
and in no way should governments
be let off the hook, nor should
the rest of us.
Nor should consumers
or investors.
SARAH MURRAY: Well,
and in some ways
it's companies' responsibility
to engage with governments
to develop the right kind of
regulations that doesn't hinder
business but does the
right thing as well.
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah.
SARAH MURRAY: I just wanted to
talk a little bit about life
as a corporate idealist and
how you get things done.
Because you didn't
go in to be a CSR.
You didn't join BP as a CSR
person or a sustainability
person.
And we have lots of those people
with lots of those titles.
But is it the case
that actually everybody
can be a corporate idealist?
And how do you do that from
within a position where,
I don't know, you're in
operations management
or HR or communications?
What would you
advise to people who
would like to get
involved in this
but are not working
in the CSR department?
CHRISTINE BADER:
Yeah, well sometimes
I think people can be in a
position of greater power
just by doing the functions that
they're doing and doing them
well and thinking
about the big picture.
I mean, in China I was on
a construction team, right?
Because our biggest
risk there, I
was sent out there
to work on a BP--
SARAH MURRAY:
Didn't know that you
learned building when
you were doing an MBA.
CHRISTINE BADER: Exactly.
Who knew that
construction was my minor.
But no.
But I went out there because
BP had a joint venture
with Sinopec, one of China's
state energy companies,
to build a really big
chemicals plant that
was going to bring in tens of
thousands of migrant workers
into a town of
about 30,000 people.
So, you know.
Could be some impacts there.
So my first week there
I was in this meeting.
And it was like half BP
guys and half Sinopec guys.
And we were going
down the spreadsheet
of the latest
estimates for the cost
and the timeline
for the project.
And there was one label
in the spreadsheet where
the number was
eight but the label
hadn't been translated
into English.
And so my BP colleague said,
what's the number eight?
What's the label?
And Sinopec guy said, oh.
That's the projected
number of fatalities.
He said, excuse me?
And he said, yeah.
Based on a project this big
with this many man hours,
we would expect
eight fatalities.
And my colleague said,
the target is not eight.
He said, the target is zero.
And the Sinopec guy said,
that's not realistic.
And he said, if you
set expectations
that you're going to
kill eight people,
you're probably going to
kill at least eight people.
And they guy said, well,
it's not realistic.
And I realized
that he was right.
Based on their track record,
it was probably realistic
that they were going
to kill eight people.
So that's the kind
of conversation
that I had to have there.
This was on the
construction team, right?
So we managed not to kill
anybody during construction.
Hurray!
But to make the case
there for example,
it took me a while to figure
out the right language to use.
So I went in there saying OK.
We're going to protect the
human rights of the workers
and of communities.
And you know, that
didn't work so well.
I mean, it just fell flat.
I didn't get thrown
out or anything.
But it just didn't work.
And then I tried, OK.
These are the standards that
BP uses for our projects
around the world and that's
what we're going to use here.
And it was like,
get out of here.
That's incredibly
arrogant, right?
So I had to shut up
for a couple of weeks
and just listen to
what resonated, right?
What are people motivated by?
What drives them?
And so finally I
came back with, OK.
I understand that you want
this to be a world class model
project.
And if that is the
case, then these
are the standards, these
international standards
on working conditions.
These are the standards that
world class model projects use.
And they're like, OK.
Why didn't you say so?
SARAH MURRAY: It's
so true, isn't it?
So many different
parts of business
have their own language.
I remember talking
to one-- no, I
think it was actually
in the oil industry
and they were saying,
take the word integrity.
If you say the word integrity
when you're standing in the CSR
department, they probably
think that you're
talking about being
honest and open
and treating your workers right.
And if you say
integrity to an engineer
he means is our oil
pipe going to blow up?
CHRISTINE BADER: Right.
It's [INAUDIBLE], yeah.
SARAH MURRAY: You know,
those language, those terms
are very powerful.
And I think one of the
things that comes out
very strongly in
your book is how
you, as corporate
idealists, how do
you connect with the
rest of the company?
But just to go
back to something I
mentioned at the beginning
of this conversation,
how do you create your community
as a corporate idealist?
You mentioned I think going to--
I think it was just after you'd
had the twins-- you
mentioned you were determined
to get to this BSR conference.
CHRISTINE BADER: I couldn't
see straight, but yeah.
SARAH MURRAY: And I think I
remember meeting you there.
You looked great by the way.
But this need to be with other
people in your community.
How would you advise people to
try building those communities
so that you don't feel such a
isolated person in this role?
CHRISTINE BADER: I
think now it's easier.
I mean, every company
has interest groups
and every company's
got a green team.
And I think it's easier.
And I think for
outside of the company
there are CSR sustainability
meetups everywhere.
So I think it's a lot easier.
But I guess one thing
that came through
in a lot of these
interviews-- and again, they
were people who I'd known
professionally for a long time
but never talked
to them about how
they found their jobs
in the first place.
And one theme that
certainly was true for me
is that I did a lot of
thinking out loud about what
I was interested in regardless
of the job that I was doing.
But what's our company's
role in society?
And oh, what's
going on over there?
I mean, you still have
to be good at your job
and focus on it, right?
But for a lot of these
people, again, they
fell into these roles
when corporate social
responsibility, CSR, was
not really a function.
So like me, they fell
into it because they
were asking lots of
questions and talking
to other people in their
company about well,
here's where I'm interested,
and what are we doing on this?
And what should we be doing?
And shouldn't we be doing this?
And I just saw a
documentary last night
and just read an
article about this,
and how do we react to that?
So that when something
opened up people
thought, oh, that person
would be really good at this.
Very rarely does a job
posting pop up on the board
and it's like, oh.
I should apply.
And then you apply.
SARAH MURRAY: You
end up doing things
from within your
existing job and probably
doing nothing in your
spare time until somebody
comes along and says, hey.
This is something we
need in the company.
CHRISTINE BADER: So
I'm a big proponent
of thinking out loud
about the things
that you're interested in.
And I have found
certainly for me
that that tends to create space
for opportunities to arise.
SARAH MURRAY: What
does that mean though
for somebody who is thinking
they would like to do this
but they're graduating
from business school?
And where do you start?
I mean, as you say,
the job that says
CSR and sustainability
could sort of mean anything.
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah.
Yeah.
SARAH MURRAY: How do
you go about that today?
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah, well I
suppose there are a few things.
I mean, within business
school there's net impact,
which is the association.
And every business school
has a net impact chapter now.
And they have their own job
boards and things specifically
for these jobs.
But I suppose when I get all
of these inquiries of people
saying, oh, I really want
to get into this field,
I ask them, well, what do you
actually want to do all day?
Do you want to be
traipsing around villages?
Do you want to be sitting
behind a desk creating policies?
So I guess like any
job you break it down.
What are the skills that I
want to be using all day?
What are the issues
that I really care
about that I want
to be working on?
Are there particular countries
that I'm really excited by
or geographies that I
have a specialty in?
And then like
anything, and there's
a little bit of serendipity
in finding the right position
with the right people
at the right company
open at the right time.
But people talk about
serendipity a lot,
and I think we give it
too much weight, right?
SARAH MURRAY: You have to
make your own opportunities
in some ways.
CHRISTINE BADER:
You have to make it.
Yeah.
Because it drives me crazy.
I mean, you guys hear a
lot of people speak here.
And I will bet you that
whenever you hear illustrious
people talk about their careers,
inevitably there was always
one moment when
they say, and then
I just got this call one day.
Right?
There's some knowing nods.
I just got this call
out of the blue one day.
And that's baloney, right?
So when they say that, ask
them to trace the call.
Because people don't
offer jobs to somebody
who they've never met before.
People offer jobs to people who,
oh, I was just playing squash
with my friend and he mentioned
that his friend's daughter
was looking for a job, right?
Or it's a conversation
that you had with somebody
three years ago.
And something just
opened up, right?
I mean, you can't control
the timing of these things.
And that's where
serendipity comes in.
But I actually think it does
a great disservice when people
talk like that, when people
say, I just got the call out
of the blue one day, because
it makes you think that you're
just supposed to sit back
and wait for the call.
SARAH MURRAY: Whereas in fact
it's a lot of asking questions,
talking about the right things.
CHRISTINE BADER: Exactly.
And thinking out loud and
building your network.
SARAH MURRAY: Absolutely.
Yeah.
Well, on that note
actually is a good moment
to see if anybody has any
questions here for Christine.
AUDIENCE: CSI's very much
like [INAUDIBLE] the company
when it tries to fix the problem
because we're a good company.
What can consumers
do to push companies
to change their practices?
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah.
That's a great question.
And I think consumers
have to ask, right?
Users have to demand.
And so I think in
this sector we saw
that here where users are
saying, well, hang on.
Why was this
information taken down?
Why am I getting
different search results
in this country than in that?
I mean, I think users and
consumers have to ask.
But frankly, I've gotten
really depressed with how
little consumers demand.
And I site some of these studies
in the book of how people
say that they will pay
more for fair trade
or sustainable
products, but there
are all these studies
that show if you've
got two piles of socks sitting
next to each other and one's
marked fair trade
and one's marked not,
people will buy the fair trade
one if they're the same price.
But as soon as you
bump the price up
people don't buy them, right?
So there's a little bit of
money where our mouth is.
But I appreciate that
that's really hard.
But I think just
asking the question.
So one of the times when
I did one of those head
to toe inventories and I
realized that there were
a couple of brands that I'm
wearing that I didn't know
anything about, I tweeted
and I just said, hey x brand.
What's your policy in
the wake of Rana Plaza?
Two of them didn't respond.
And so I re-tweeted
and I said, bummer.
You're not responding.
I'm not buying any
more of your stuff.
One of them I posted something
on their Facebook page
and they wrote this
long, awesome response
of how well, we try
to establish long term
relationships with
our suppliers,
et cetera, et cetera.
And I hadn't verified
it yet, but I
think it was a pretty
awesome response.
And there were lots of other
people who liked the comment.
So I think asking the questions
again is really important.
We have to ask.
And it makes the job of the
people inside the company
a lot easier to be
able to say, look.
This isn't my imagination
that this is important.
Well, there are a couple
of interesting ways
that I talk about
this in the book.
One of them, I interviewed a
lot of advocates an activists.
And again, they're people who
I've known for a long time
but I had never actually talked
to them about their tactics
and how they think
about their work.
So there were some
human rights advocates
that said, actually, we see
our job as creating space
inside the company for
you to do your job better.
Which were so interesting.
And one other person
inside a company
said, you know, I used to
have to call up quietly one
of my NGO or socially
responsible investor friends
to say, now would be
a really good time
for you to write a
letter to my CEO.
And you don't really
have to do that anymore
because they're
a hashtag, right?
You don't need to
do that anymore.
But I think users and consumers
absolutely have to ask.
SARAH MURRAY: And technology has
made that so possible in a way
that it never was before.
I mean, you can immediately
contact a company
and ask them a question.
CHRISTINE BADER: On
Twitter, on Facebook, yeah.
SARAH MURRAY: I mean, years ago
you had to write them a letter
and it probably ended
up in some backwater.
CHRISTINE BADER: Right.
Because nobody else ever saw
that you wrote the letter.
SARAH MURRAY: Right.
CHRISTINE BADER: Right?
SARAH MURRAY: Exactly.
So they didn't
have to answer it.
CHRISTINE BADER: Exactly.
And now it's out there.
SARAH MURRAY: Yes.
It's all public.
So yeah.
Another question?
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much
for being here first of all.
Appreciate it.
How do you deal with
the-- my thought
process is it must be very
disheartening at times
when you see something
like BP oil spill happen.
And a couple of years on, zero
conversation really happening
about it.
But with our
ecosystems [INAUDIBLE]
disintegrated by all accounts I
think during that time period.
So I guess for something like
environmental issues or climate
change, something like
that, it's kind of,
we're on a ticking clock.
Versus something
like labor rights
which might take their
time from a policy
level down to the grassroots.
How do you deal with something
like the environment,
and do you get
disheartened [INAUDIBLE]?
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah, sure.
I mean again,
that's a lot of what
compelled me to write the book.
Because it was after
the Deepwater Horizon
disaster, it was like,
[SIGHS]
CHRISTINE BADER: What is it?
Like, what does it mean?
Are we making any
difference at all,
or is this completely useless?
So again, not to give
away the punchline,
but I don't think it's
completely useless.
But I think that all
of us as individuals
need to decide, what role
do we want to play, right?
And so some of us need to be
inside companies and fighting
that incremental,
everyday, like trying just
to tweak some practices
that take a long time.
And some of us need to be
shouting from the rooftops
and being activists and
protesting out on the street.
And obviously, those rules
have their frustrations too.
But I do have faith that
all of the people who
are doing this work do
believe that they're
making a difference.
And one of the
themes that really
came through loud
and clear which was,
again, I didn't expect,
it was the optimism
of people who are
doing this work.
So one friend who's
worked in supply chains
for a number of apparel
companies, he went on a visit
to visit factories in India.
And then the guy who was showing
him around said, let me just
take you to one factory
that's not on your list.
It supplies the domestic market.
Just to show you what it's like.
And he walked in there.
He said, it was filthy.
There was a 10-year-old
kid on one of the machines.
And it was horrible.
And I said, well, what did
that feel like to see that?
And he said, well,
he said, it opened up
this whole other
question that I don't
know what to do with of what
do we do with factories that
are supplying the domestic
market that aren't
held to international standards?
And he said, but actually
I left optimistic.
Because I thought if these
were what the factories that do
supply us looked like
20 or 30 years ago,
we have made a big difference.
And it's that optimism that
I saw over and over again.
One guy who works for
a big mining company
and went to Papau New Guinea
on his first day of work
and saw the extent of
domestic violence there.
And was trying to
think about, well,
what role could or should
or does the company play?
Are we exacerbating it?
How could we make it better?
And I thought,
and I said to him,
wasn't that incredibly
overwhelming and disheartening
to see that this is what
you're stepping into?
And he said, I thought
this was an opportunity
to do really good
human rights work,
that this is a place
where we could actually
make a difference.
So yeah.
It's incredibly disheartening.
But what are you
going to do about it?
Are you going to do nothing?
Like, we've all got
to do something.
And it's just,
what is ours to do?
SARAH MURRAY: And different
people have different roles.
I mean, I think even
within the NGO community,
it was interesting.
I was talking to somebody
from Greenpeace the other day.
And he was saying, we
pave the way for the NGOs
who are going to work with
companies by giving them
the agenda to do that.
It makes it easier for
us to show up at the door
when Greenpeace has been
out there hammering away.
So I think there is
this sort of ecosystem
of forces that will
shift companies.
I think we have-- [INAUDIBLE].
Yes, that's right.
Another question there.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so
much for being here.
So one thing that really
struck me about your book
was this feeling
of being isolated
as a corporate idealist
in a massive company.
And I was wondering
if you could speak
about creating a culture
of accountability
in a huge company
such as Google or BP.
The supply chain
is just so massive.
So for the Gap example that
you presented about the sub
subcontractor hiring
these laborers as opposed
to corporate has that
Gap saying let's hire.
How do you manage
for accountability
in these huge supply
chains and also,
if you could speak about your
experience at BP or elsewhere,
just creating that culture of
accountability among people?
CHRISTINE BADER:
And by that, do you
mean a culture of taking
responsibility for those issues
that previously somebody might
have said that's not our--
AUDIENCE: Right.
[INAUDIBLE] subcontractors
because it's no
longer in our hands.
Yeah.
CHRISTINE BADER: Yeah.
That's a great question.
Let me think to
my own experience.
Again, I guess so
in China it was
about trying to make
the case that we
are accountable for those issues
whether we like it or not.
And I think that's been
a big theme in this field
for a long time of companies.
Every company's sort of
going through this journey.
And it's like the seven
stages of grieving, right?
Or that first there's
this denial, right?
And we saw this with
Nike with sweatshops
and we saw it with
Shell in Nigeria.
And we even saw it, I
think, with censorship
when the first wave sort of hit
this industry and these cases
coming to the fore of companies
saying, not my responsibility.
That somebody else's
responsibility.
And then I think realizing,
it's like, you know what?
That's not good enough.
And whether or not legally
this is your responsibility,
the court of public
opinion believes
that it's your responsibility.
So I think a lot of companies
started taking responsibility
because they realized,
well, I guess it is now.
So I think there are a few
factors that make that happen.
One of them is
external pressure.
And so we saw this with Apple
when the big "New York Times"
expose came out about
working conditions
in Foxconn factories.
And at first Apple
sort of demurred.
I mean, they've been working
on supply chain responsibility
for a long time.
This wasn't new.
But we really saw them
step up after there
was so much public pressure
and join the Fair Labor
Association.
Which is a big deal for
Apple in particular, right?
To have third party
auditors come in
and inspect their
supplier factories.
And actually for Google to join
the Global Network Initiative,
that's a huge step because that
requires third party auditors
to come in and look
at your processes.
And you guys know
better than anybody.
I mean, do you let
anybody in here
to poke around
and look at stuff?
Like, that's
actually a big deal.
But I think that your company's
leadership realized, because
of what enough of you were
saying also inside the company.
And be like, hey, we need
to step up our game here
if we're really going
to live out our values
and take responsibility
for what we're doing
and be the most trusted
company for people.
This is what we need to do.
So again, I think
in every company
there are going to be different
drivers and pressures that
will create that culture.
But I think in all of
those cases a lot of it
will come from within,
of people saying, folks,
this is simply
what we need to do.
But I think it's different
in every company.
SARAH MURRAY: And
I think there are
a lot of-- I mean,
shareholders for a start,
are starting, in
some cases, starting
to push the companies that
they own into disclosure.
And then you have the power
of a company like Walmart
that can say, well,
look here suppliers.
You've all got to meet certain
environmental standards as
if you're actually
going to sell to us.
So I think there's a
range of pressures.
But you're right.
I mean, the internal is a
very important one as well.
I think we might have
time for one more.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
One more question.
[INAUDIBLE]
CHRISTINE BADER:
If there is one.
SARAH MURRAY: If there is one.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
Well, I just want to thank
Christine and Sarah so
much for coming to
speak with us today.
It was a great conversation
and lots of issues
that Google's thinking about
too in a very different context.
So interesting to hear
all of those perspectives.
So thank you again.
I really appreciate it.
SARAH MURRAY: Thank you.
CHRISTINE BADER:
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]